Star Trek: Picard has come and gone and the
biggest surprise of the season might be that the
crew of the Enterprise-D got a happy ending. But
could there be more adventures in their future?
If every Star Trek fan had sat down and watched
the Star Trek: Picard Season 3 finale at the
same time, their collective sighs of relief
at the end of the episode would have been
deafening. Despite numerous close calls and
fake-outs, the returning cast of Star Trek:
The Next Generation all made it out of the
season-long caper alive. The uplifting ending
enjoyed by these characters has certainly been
welcomed by fans, but some may be wondering
how none of the original Next Generation
crew bit the dust throughout the story.
In an interview with Inverse, Picard
showrunner Terry Matalas spoke about
the creative team's decision to keep all
the classic crew members alive. He said:
"Honestly, it would be very easy to
kill off one of these characters,
and it would be entirely appropriate. But I
didn't have it in me to do it. In a weird way,
I wanted the surprise ending to
be that it was a happy ending."
A desire for a happy ending might
have been the main reason that
the writers ended up keeping every
Next Generation crew member alive,
but there may also be another reason for the
decision. The Picard finale is meant to be
a final farewell to several major characters,
including the titular captain himself. However,
there's a slight chance that Matalas might return
to a few of the characters in a future project.
In the finale's shocking post-credits scene, Jack
Crusher encounters Q who he believed to be dead.
"Young mortal, you have much ahead of you."
Q cryptically suggests that Jack is
due for a trial, leaving a dangling
plot thread that would be ripe for a Picard
spin-off to tackle. Matalas tells Inverse:
"I know how this would all go if
we were lucky enough to come back."
If Matalas ends up developing another series, it's
quite possible that the plot he envisions could
involve characters from The Next Generation. The
same is true for the broader sphere of Star Trek
projects. By keeping the classic crew alive,
there's always the potential that they could
be brought back for another adventure if the
situation calls for it. In essence, Picard
gave its characters a happy ending with just
enough narrative wiggle room to bring them back.
It seems that many veteran cast members of Star
Trek: The Next Generation aren't ready to say
goodbye to their characters just yet either.
During the release of Picard's third season,
Patrick Stewart was candid about returning to
the franchise once more. He told reporters:
"There is still enormous potential
for matters in what we can do and
there are doors left open and
we didn't close all of them."
Several months later, Stewart expressed interest
to Variety in returning for a Star Trek:
Legacy spin-off along with Ed Speelers. He noted:
"If I can occasionally crop up to
offer a little bit of comedy myself,
then I shall be happy to do that."
Several of Stewart's fellow Next Generation
actors have voiced similar wishes. Jonathan
Frakes seems keen on returning as Riker, as
he tweeted a vague message indicating that
Star Trek: Picard might not be his final
go-around with the franchise. Meanwhile,
LeVar Burton and Brent Spiner said in a joint
interview with Variety that, while they have some
reservations about returning beyond Picard, they
aren't shutting the door completely. Spiner said:
"LeVar and I've talked about the fact that
if this lands in a way that we hope it lands,
maybe it would be best to be the finale. And
if there should be something more than this,
well, as he said, that would just be another gift
that we can't really contemplate at the moment."